A proof of work protocol
is a vehicle really
by which somebody
can effectively
prove to you that
they've engaged
in a significant amount
of computational effort.
Proof of work protocols
often amount to puzzles.
And these puzzles that
can, on the one hand,
be challenging to
solve-- and by that
I mean they require some
serious computational effort
and really can't be
short circuited--
but on the other hand,
that effort can actually
be easily verified, and it can
be verified in far less time
than it took to conduct that
effort in the first place.
OK.
And there are a number of
applications of such protocols.
So for example, if you've heard
of the Bitcoin, the Bitcoin
electronic payment system,
that system actually
leverages a proof of work
scheme within the context
of creating what are known
as transaction block chains.
Now aside from Bitcoin,
which is a very recent user
of these types of
proof of work schemes,
these schemes have been
proposed in the past
for other applications.
For example, proof
of work schemes
have been proposed
for doing things
like deterring denial-of-service
attacks, or DoS attacks.
And here the idea is
that the requester
of a particular
service would have
to solve a very specific
computational problem, a proof
of work puzzle, before being
allowed to use a service.
And the idea here is that the
computational effort exerted
is effectively a way to
throttle the requester.
The responder can,
in turn, easily
check if the requester carried
out the requisite work,
and only if that work was
carried out will the responder
respond to that
request for service.
Now the original
application for these types
of proof of work
protocols, the first place
that I've seen it
proposed, is in the context
of being able to
deter spam email.
And then obviously, we all know
what spam email is hopefully.
These are messages that you
don't want in your inbox that
maybe come to you in
an unsolicited fashion.
And the idea here is that
a proof of work protocol,
it turns out it can be tied
to a particular email message.
And this is conceptually
like affixing a postage stamp
to a message, but rather than
paying for that stamp using
money, you're basically paying
for that stamp via CPU cycles.
So for a legitimate sender
who is only sending out
a small number of messages, this
type of proof of work protocol
will not amount to very much.
It's going to be a minor
deterrent since it's only
executed a very small
number of times.
It's kind of an
impediment, but it's not
something that's
so unreasonable.
Now for a spammer, who might be
sending out a lot of messages,
maybe hundreds of thousands,
or millions of messages,
it might be prohibitively
expensive to repeatedly expend
so many CPU cycles for each
message and each sender
to whom that message
is being sent.
So hopefully this
gives you a flavor
for some of the applications of
these proof of work protocols.
Let me actually dive in to
how they work in practice.
So first of all,
the way that I like
to think of these protocols
is that typically, they
work relative to a
given challenge string.
And I'm going to
call this challenge
string-- we'll label
it with the letter c.
So c's going to be kind
of a challenge string.
And what the person trying to
engage in the protocol will do,
the prover of the
work, will basically
try to come up with a
corresponding proof that
is tied to this
challenge string.
It's going to be kind
of a response associated
with this challenge.
It has a very specific
mathematical property
in relation to this challenge.
And as you point out, maybe when
I talk about a challenge string
here, for example in
the context of spam,
this challenge
string might actually
represent an email message.
So it's going to
be something very
specific to the task at hand.
Now what the prover will do is
come up with a response string,
and let's call the
response string r.
Actually, let's use
the term p for it,
since maybe we can think
of it as a proof, a proof
or a response.
And the idea is that the prover
will come up with this proof
or response string, and he has
to come up with a string such
that, when you concatenate the
challenge and the response,
and you take the two
together, and you apply
a cryptographic hash
function-- so let's
say I come up with
a cryptographic hash
function, like SHA-256, or
anything of that nature.
If I take the challenge
string and the proof string
and concatenate together and
apply the cryptographic hash
function, apply these
mathematical transformations
that represent the
cryptographic hash function,
I want to come up with
a proof string such
that the output under
this hash function
will have a very
specific property.
The prefix of the output, the
first large number of bits
will all be 0.
So let's say the first 40
bits, or first 30 bits,
or some number of
bits will be 0.
And then the other bits can be
whatever they would normally
be.
So obviously, what
you're trying to do here
is come up with a
proof string that
has a relationship with
the challenge string.
And that relationship
happens to be
one that is taken with respect
to a particular hash function,
and really incorporates
or considers
what the output of
the hash function
will be when the proof string is
concatenated with the challenge
string.
And if you, let's say, have
a good cryptographic hash
function, then
the only known way
to find this type
of a proof string
is to effectively try a lot
of different possibilities,
effectively doing
brute force, by trying
a lot of different proof strings
until you find one that works.
Now if you, let's
say, needed to find
an output that contained about
40 consecutive 0's in it, that
would require you to
perform about 2 to the power
40 steps, 2 to the power
40 different hash function
indications.
You'd have to try 2 to the
40 different strings, and one
of them what would likely
work if you tried 2
to the 40 such strings.
That actually requires you to
try about, and 2 to the 40 just
to give you a sense, is
approximately 1 trillion.
So if you tried a trillion
different strings out,
and you hashed them
each, you would likely
come up with one string that
had the first 40 bits being 0.
Now sometimes it might
take you a lot less
than a trillion steps.
Sometimes it might take
you a little bit more.
You may get very lucky.
You might get very unlucky.
But on average, it will take
you about 1 trillion steps
to find a string where the
first 40 bits are equal to 0.
So this is something
that's not easy,
but it's also not outside
the realm of possibility.
Now to understand
why it's really hard
to solve these types of
proof of work schemes more
efficiently than maybe
simply doing brute force,
I think it's helpful to
recall that the output
of a cryptographic hash function
looks more or less random.
In fact, each output bit looks
like a series of coin flips.
So it's kind of like
flipping the coin,
and if it comes up heads,
you would have a 0,
and if it comes up tails,
you can think of it as a 1.
And so what you're
really doing is
saying, if I flipped 40 coins,
what are the odds that you
would have 40 consecutive
heads on those 40 coin flips?
Now obviously that
likelihood is very small,
but it's not outside the
realm of possibility.
If you flipped 40 coins and
you flipped those 40 coins
about a trillion times,
you would actually
expect to see one instance
in which all 40 coins came up
as heads out of
a trillion tries.
Now one interesting thing with
these proof of work schemes,
is they can be ratcheted
up or ratcheted down.
So for example,
let's say you want
to require even more
computational heavy lifting
to come up with a
correct proof string.
Let's say you want to
increase the work that's
going to be proved here.
What you can effectively
do, in that case,
is you could just increase
the requirement on a number
of leading 0's.
So every time you
add an additional 0,
you effectively double the
computational horsepower
needed on average.
And that's because
you effectively
requiring one more coin
flip to come up heads,
and that entails doubling
the number of coin flips.
So if I had 41 coin flips and
I required 41 straight heads,
that would require about
twice as much effort
as just requiring
40 straight heads.
And likewise, every time you
remove a 0 from consideration,
or the requirement,
that will reduce
the computational horsepower
needed to about half
of what it was previously.
So for example, if I only
required the first 39 bits
to be 0, that would require
about half as many coin flips
as requiring the
first 40 bits to be 0.
Now the neat thing is that once
you come up with a solution--
let's say that somebody
tries a trillion times
and they finally come up
with a proof string that
works-- it's very easy to
validate that this proof
string is in fact a
correct proof of work.
All you have to do is,
you take the challenge
and you take the proof string
and you hash them together.
So for example, if somebody
proposes this one string,
let's call it p prime, all you
do is you take the challenge
and you take p prime,
and you input them
into a hash
function, and you see
if the first 40 bits are all 0.
So all this requires you to do
is apply a hash function once
to the concatenation
of c and p prime,
and you can verify
that the output indeed
has the requisite number
of 0's in front of it.
And if you see that the output
has the requisite number
of 0's, then you can consider
the proof of work valid,
because you know it must
have taken somebody a lot
of time, a lot of tries
really, to provide or come up
with the string p prime, such
that the concatenation of c
and p prime gives
you a number of 0's
under the application of this
cryptographic hash function.
So as you can see, these
schemes are quite simple,
but quite clever
at the same time.
They really amount to coming
up with a proof string that
has a very specific,
mathematical relationship
with the original
challenge string.
So hopefully this
video gave you a flavor
for the mechanics of how these
proof of work protocols work.